The Anom-O-Tron 6000 - You know what it is
and what it does.
Not too long ago, we had it simulate a battle
between the SCP Foundation and the slimy,
sinister superhero Homelander, who terrorizes
the world of The Boys.
And in the comments, we kept seeing one name
pop up: Omniman.
The terrifying, almost unstoppable, Viltrumite
warrior who scared the hell out of all of
us in Invincible.
So, we decided to run a simulation to see
if the SCP Foundation could find the same
success battling this diabolical corrupted
superman.
The video you’re about to see is that simulation.
Enjoy, and keep an eye on the skies!
It was unthinkable.
Panic had spread throughout the Foundation
as reports came in that several of the most
high-profile groups of interest across the
globe had suffered unbearably brutal attacks
from an unknown assailant.
Notable among the groups targeted were GOC
- Global Occult Coalition - as well as its
opposing organization: The Serpent’s Hand.
In all incidents, key buildings belonging
to the groups were demolished, and the bodies
of all leadership personnel were discovered
beaten to a pulp.
These massacres appeared to send a terrifying
message: whoever was behind these attacks,
the Foundation was most likely next on the
chopping block.
As all containment sites prepared for the
worst, it was Site 17 that received subsequent
news on the matter in the most unsettling
way imaginable.
A small flying object was discovered in the
site’s airspace, and retrieved by an MTF-issue
helicopter.
The object appeared to be an action figure
of world-renowned superhero Omniman, and it
bore the trademark of Dr. Wondertainment Toys.
The Mobile Task Force that discovered the
action figure had been on such high alert
that the appearance of this toy almost seemed
comical.
There was uneasy laughter within the helicopter,
which immediately turned to silence when the
toy began to speak.
“Boys and girls, for the very first time,
Dr. Wondertainment presents to you … ‘Run!
Run for your lives!
Omniman is coming for all of us!’”
The toy continued what was apparently a prerecorded
voice over, which became increasingly frightened
and desperate as it went along.
The contents of the recording confirmed that
the one responsible for the devastation of
the other groups of interest was none other
than Omniman himself.
His reasons for doing this were unknown, but
he seemed adamant on wiping out all groups
with significant control over the planet’s
anomalies.
Whoever was in charge at Dr. Wondertainment
had uncovered the truth shortly before Omniman
arrived to do the same to their group, and
had deployed the toy in a last ditch effort
to warn the SCP Foundation.
It was an uncharacteristically opaque gesture
from the terrible toymaker, but the Foundation
had little choice but to take it seriously.
If Earth’s most powerful superhero had really
gone rogue and was going after influential
organizations in some bid to eliminate competition,
the Foundation would have to develop appropriate
countermeasures as soon as possible.
The first priority was securing the safety
of the 05 council, who would most likely be
the intended victims of Omniman’s rampage.
Fortunately, their current location was extremely
classified, so rather than shuffle to a new
location, the council chose to stay where
they were.
A conspicuous relocation process could inadvertently
give the game away, especially if the aptly
named “Aww, [Redacted] it!
Just launch us into Space!”
procedure was in-effect.
Omniman was known for his spacefaring capabilities,
and was fully capable of pursuing and boarding
the 05 council’s getaway shuttle if such
a thing was attempted.
Additionally, there would be no movement of
forces to the location of the 05 council.
Mobile Task Forces that were already in the
field would be instructed to immediately cease
their current mission and focus on locating
Omniman.
While the superhero was incredibly dangerous,
it was paramount that valuable time was bought
so that a better attack plan could be formulated.
That was one advantage the Foundation had
over most of the other groups of interest:
the reserves to prolong a war of attrition,
no matter how strong the enemy was.
There was also the matter of establishing
protections for Site-17, since Wondertainment
had sent the action figure there of all places
to deliver the message, it was likely that
Omniman would be headed there first.
Site staff requested the immediate transfer
of the infamous Mobile Task Force Tau-5 Samsara
- a unit of immortal cyborgs with superhuman
physiology.
While Omniman was known to have fought and
defeated everything from the spawn of ancient
gods, to cyborgs, to immortals: The four members
of samsara were all three and had strength
in numbers.
The request remained pending for several minutes,
causing one researcher to blithely remark
that the 05 council had probably called dibs.
Fearing that MTF Tau-5 wouldn’t arrive in
time to intercept Omniman, the researchers
assessed which anomalies contained on site
would be best suited to holding the superhero
back.
One keter-class SCP in particular immediately
came to mind: SCP-4051 - a male humanoid with
the anomalous ability to create extradimensional
wormholes.
These wormholes could be used to produce any
object that SCP-4051 desired, including exceedingly
unstable cognitohazards.
While SCP-4051’s powers were certainly formidable,
it was the fact that the humanoid - who went
by the name Rainer Miller - had previously
been acting as a vigilante in the United States.
In other words, Rainer Miller was likely to
be of special interest to Omniman - even if
that interest merely amounted to having one
more target to wipe out.
While it wouldn’t be the only humanoid SCP
that could be considered similar to a superhero,
4051 was definitely the closest at hand.
Not too long after the discussion took place,
the site radars began to pick up on Omniman
closing in.
His approach was extraordinarily fast, breaking
through the sound barrier, and landing with
great force in the center of Site-17.
There was no time to waste, and all available
guards and Mobile Task Forces personnel were
ordered to zero-in on Omniman’s location
and open fire.
As one might expect, bullets weren’t exactly
effective against the superhero-turned-serial
killer, but they did provide a plausible distraction
while the researchers mobilized to find other
means of neutralizing Omniman.
It was a terrifying sight watching the costumed
man stand there within the hail of bullets,
bearing no outward signs of distress aside
from a stern facial expression.
He moved smoothly through the air towards
the nearest soldier and shattered every rib
with a single punch.
He then grabbed another and used him to bludgeon
several other agents.
Even with the substantial advantage in raw
power, there was a considered tactical reason
for each of Omniman’s movements.
He systematically made his way through the
site, crushing all within his path with absolute
prejudice.
There were going to be no survivors if this
continued.
Fortunately, one of the Site-17 other contingencies
was about to come into play.
You see, The Foundation had done their research,
and with the corroboration of information
from other groups including the United States
government had deduced that Omniman might
have a psychological weakness that could be
exploited.
Namely, his teenage son Mark - otherwise known
by his superhero alias Invincible.
While the Foundation was far too cautious
to directly contact Invincible - mostly out
of fear that the boy could be an accomplice,
the next best thing could still stall Omniman
- and give the researchers a chance to get
SCP-4051 ready for combat.
It certainly took Omniman by surprise when
he was floating down one of the newly blood-soaked
corridors and saw Invincible standing at the
end, staring him down.
“Dad?
What is going on?
Why are you hurting them?” said what appeared
to be Mark.
Omniman stopped in place and his expression
changed a look of concern.
For the first time since he had arrived at
Site 17, Omniman spoke.
“Mark?”
“Come on, Dad, this is crazy!
You should stop this and go back home to mom!”
Omniman furrowed his brow.
Something was off here.
For one, this version of Invincible had both
feet on the ground, even though he would have
all the same powers of his father.
Also, the fact that Invincible hadn’t approached
suggested that this individual was in such
fear of Omniman that it refused to approach.
Omniman had been caught off guard by this
at first, worried that his son could be afraid
of him to this extent, but it was starting
to seem suspicious.
Mark was no coward - he had become a superhero
like his father because he wanted to protect
the world from all manner of threats.
Although the difference in combat experience
between the two was vast, Omniman knew that
the Invincible he knew was reckless enough
to challenge him or at least have this conversation
at a regular distance.
His intuition was right on the money as this
was not Invincible at all, but SCP-953 - the
polymorphic humanoid - instead.
While this keter-class SCP was known for taking
many forms - usually that of beautiful women
- the Foundation staff had given it access
all available information on Omniman and Invincible’s
father-son relationship and in doing so successfully
convinced it that taking the form of Omniman’s
son was the best path the self-preservation
during this perilous scenario.
SCP-953 continued to make attempts at talking
Omniman, doing its best to remain still - not
wanting to reveal the vulpine features beneath
the Invincible costume it was wearing.
But Omniman proved to be too clever for this
gambit.
He chuckled, then suddenly zoomed forward
with his fist raised in front of him.
SCP-953 flinched in terror, only to find that
Omniman had pulled his punch.
At first, SCP-953 was relieved to still be
intact but this soon dissipated as the humanoid
looked at Omniman and found none of the compassion
that was on his face just moments ago.
“You’re not Mark,” Omniman said.
“He’s stronger than this.”
SCP-953 trembled in fear.
The polymorphic humanoid only had one card
left to play, and it prayed that it worked.
953 shapeshifted again, this time into Omniman’s
wife Debbie.
Her fox-like features were more pronounced
in this form, but it was clear that the sight
of his human partner’s face made Omniman
hesitant to attack.
This hesitation was all the time that the
polymorphic humanoid needed to run away, as
several guards and SCP-4051 arrived to take
over the duty of stalling Omniman.
Several wormholes opened up around Omniman,
deploying sonic grenades which stunned him
for several seconds.
The guards unleashed all their ammo, and drew
Omniman’s aggression while Rainer prepared
his next weapon - a wormhole to a pocket dimension
filled with flamethrowers, which he directed
at Omniman, hoping to at least cause some
lasting pain if not proper burns.
The flames did temporarily obscure his vision,
but they didn’t hinder him for long as Omniman
moved straight upwards through the ceiling
before descending back down into the building,
massacring the guards surrounding SCP-4051.
He looked on Rainer with disdain, especially
as the humanoid opened a wormhole and pulled
out an aluminum baseball bat.
“You really think that piece of earthling
sports equipment is going to do anything to
me?”
Omniman said.
“It doesn’t matter if it does or doesn’t.”
Rainer replied.
“You’re not the hero you once were, and
someone has to try and stop you.”
Omniman paused, reminded of his own son.
Though mere sentiment wouldn’t be to spare
Rainer Miller the fate of the rest of his
planet and its people.
Omniman went in for the kill, but Rainer opened
a wormhole directly in front of himself, which
contained multiple anti-tank rifles that fired
in Omniman’s direction.
The impact didn’t phase Omniman, but it
slowed the superhero down just enough for
Rainer to tuck and roll behind him.
Rainer reached into another wormhole for a
gas-mask which he quickly donned as another
one of his wormholes unleashed deadly poison
gas into the corridor.
Omniman held his breath and flew towards Rainer,
grabbing his aluminum bat mid-swing and bending
it into an L-shape without any apparent effort.
Rainer let go of his weapon, but Omniman quickly
grabbed him by the wrist and lifted him into
the air before slamming him down to the ground.
Rainer Miller - SCP-4051 - was incapacitated,
perhaps fatally.
Before Omniman could confirm his kill - he
was tackled and immediately thrown through
the nearest wall by the combined force of
four individuals in cybernetic armor.
Mobile Task Force Tau-5 Samsara had arrived,
and together, they surrounded Omniman and
hit him with everything they had.
Punches and kicks bombarded him from all angles,
offering barely any window for a response.
The formation didn’t last long, as Omniman
withstood the hits and maneuvered behind one
of the members of Samsara, grabbing and snapping
the cyborgs neck in one quick motion.
One of its fellows swung for Omniman’s face
only for him to catch the blow and severely
batter the arm of the attacker - rendering
it unusable.
Omniman grabbed the last two members by the
throats and squeezed until he heard the familiar
pop and crack, then he let their bodies fall.
Of course, this wasn’t enough to neutralize
Samsara completely.
The cyborgs were down, but not out - as their
fast regeneration began to fix their injuries.
With detached contempt, Omniman stomped forcefully
on their heads - shattering the skulls of
each member of Samsara one by one.
That should be a lot harder to fix.
Omniman thought to himself.
He was almost finished here, then it would
be on to the next containment site, and eventually
to the 05 council itself.
His planet wouldn’t need meddlesome groups
like the SCP Foundation - made up of inferior
humans playing at civilization.
He’d make sure they knew how powerless they
were before the rest of the people of Viltrum
arrived to complete the conquest of Earth.
He applauded the short-lived bravery of Rainer
Miller, and in an uncharacteristic moment
of mercy, chose not to go back and check if
his previous opponent had truly been killed.
Omniman rationalized that he already inflicted
a killing blow, but deep down - as he concluded
his rampage through Site 17 and departed for
the site of his next slaughter - he knew that
he subconsciously gave the boy a chance to
live.
Want to own an SCP of your own?
Go to scpswag.com for premium anomalous merchandise!
Now go check out “Could Homelander's Ego
Crush The SCP Foundation?”
and “SCP-076 Able VS Chainsaw Man...Who
Has The Most Lethal Weapon?”
for more crossovers with the world’s wildest
superheroes!